[Applause]
[Music]
japan
against korea korea against japan japan
against china
china against japan korea vs china china
versus korea
and meanwhile north korea and taiwan are
stuck in the middle dear friends
east asia has become if it hasn't always
been a hotbed of confrontation and
diplomatic crisis between the
three most powerful neighbors in the
region china japan and south korea
conflicts that sometimes
to the western eye may seem ridiculous
but in east asia are much more than
simple territorial conflicts of who owns
which tiny island
islands that in some cases as we will
see a little later on
are not much more than lumps of rock the
problem
if we can call it that is that in this
part of the world along with the
territorial issue there is a component
of honour nationalism and a feeling of a
need for self-defense that has a lot to
do with the dark events of the 20th
century
events that occurred less than 80 years
ago
[Music]
during the first half of the 20th
century japan carried out an aggressive
campaign to expand its empire in east
asia and also in southeast asia which
began in 1904 with the russia-japanese
war and ended with the capitulation
of the japanese empire in 1945. that
imperial expansion cost
tens of millions of lives including
those of millions of civilians who lost
their lives in numerous massacres
indiscriminate attacks
executions human experiments and a host
of other atrocities that were later
recognized
as war crimes this expansionist campaign
involved the occupation of numerous
countries
although the signing of the 1951 treaty
of san francisco regulated the return of
all the territories of the former
colonies
to their respective nations after the
fall of the japanese empire certain
legal loopholes and ambiguities have led
japan to still claim some of them
as its own
[Music]
this is why some of the victims of the
japanese empire pull out their claws
every time japan says that this
or that territory is theirs of course
this is not the only reason you need to
factor
in the growing influence of china and
the fierce struggle for every square
meter of the exclusive economic zones
that has also fueled many of these
political confrontations
[Music]
the most notorious cases are the senkaku
islands which japan disputes
with both china and taiwan the dokdo
islands
of south korea and with considerably
less media noise the southern parts of
the russian kuril islands as well as the
southern athol aquino turishima this
place okinoterishima is a place that
you've probably never heard of but it
has a curious history behind it
friends in this video we're going to
tell you exactly what's behind all these
territorial conflicts conflicts which in
some cases have made the waters that
separate japan from china
south korea and russia a hot spot hotter
than a hot pot listen up because there
is so much more ground to cover in this
story than we could ever imagine at
first glance
so let's get into it senkaku the
manufactured conflict
friends have you ever heard of the
senkaku islands or maybe you're more
familiar with their chinese name
dia you and i know that i probably
pronounced that incorrectly to those of
you watching this video from the west
which will be the majority it is likely
that you will have not heard of them
either however
in east asia things are very very
different
the senkaku islands are a group of five
islands and three
completely uninhabited rocks that lie
between japan taiwan and mainland china
the closest islands to the three
countries is in a strategic position 170
kilometers from taiwan 170 kilometers
from the japanese island of ishigaki and
330 kilometers from the coast of
mainland china
like so many other islands in the area
japan recognized them as its own
territory in 1895 just before beginning
its military expansion when japan's
strategy was to reclaim uninhabited
territory in any relatively nearby
islands the senkaku group of islands
never had more than 200 inhabitants
mainly fishermen who took advantage of
the rich fishing grounds in the
surrounding area
[Music]
anyway the curious thing about this
story is not so much how the japanese
claimed their sovereignty over this
territory but what they did
afterwards the empire of japan
privatised the senkaku islands in 1932
when it sold them to the koga family who
intended to establish a food production
centre there in 1940 however their
project collapsed and after the japanese
defeat in 1945
the islands came under the
administration of the united states
which also
administered all of japan until 1952.
these islands however remained under u.s
control
for two more decades right up until
1972. in that year
not only were the senkaku returned to
japanese sovereignty but four of the
islands were also bought by a different
family the kurihara family and friends
that's exactly when this whole mess
started
[Music]
with the return of the islands by the
united states to japan china and taiwan
simultaneously began to claim them as
their own
based on their proximity and a
historical dispute over maritime
elimination
actually using their arguments the
islands would belong to taiwan but
of course since communist china does not
recognize taiwan as a country they've
claimed them as their own but at the end
of the day we
are talking about uninhabited islands
without much apparent interest
so the diplomatic and territorial
conflicts fell dormant over the years
without causing major problems that is
until 2012 when it suddenly stirred
again
as i've said many times before although
the united states does not take a
position
on the ultimate sovereignty of the
islands we acknowledge they are under
the administration of japan
clinton's comments have angered china's
leadership mr lay said her statements
quote
confused right with wrong
so what do you think could have happened
in 2012 to reignite the senkaku problem
well japan decided to
nationalize the islands yes yes
nationalized them it bought the islands
back from the kurihara family and made
the protection of the archipelago a
national priority
even expanding the military units
deployed around them this prompted china
to send a maritime surveillance aircraft
to fly over the island's airspace for
the first time
since 1958 not only that chinese raids
and japanese responses with similar acts
have been constant ever since and in
fact we're reaching a peak at the time
of making this video with chinese coast
guard ships
regularly patrolling these islands now
what has led china to
expand its pressure and vigilance over
the senkaku group well surprisingly
it boils down to this
vote in japan to change status of
disputed islands threatens to raise
tensions with china the ishigaki city
council in japan's okinawa prefecture
approved the legislation that
changes the administrative status of the
uninhabited island group
known as the senkakus in japan and dius
in china the bill changes the name of
the islands for administrative purposes
from tonoshiro to tono shirou senkaku
cnn a name change although it seems hard
to believe a simple change of name by a
city council was enough to unleash a
diplomatic skirmish
yayou island and the affiliated islands
are china's inherent territory
china is resolute in safeguarding our
territorial sovereignty this so-called
administrative redesignation is a
serious provocation towards china's
territorial sovereignty
jiao legian a spokesperson for china's
foreign ministry don't tell me it
doesn't seem like a joke
but the reality is stranger this is how
things work
in east asia the fact is that legally
with the law in hand
there is no doubt that the senkaku
islands are currently japanese territory
and the claims of taiwan and china do
not seem to have much of a bearing
of course with xi jinping at the helm of
china you never know
however as we mentioned at the beginning
of this video this is by no means the
only territorial conflict japan has
opened the other major conflict is that
of the dokdo islands
which directly involve south korea and
let's just say that these two countries
get along like cats and dogs listen up
it's not the islands it's our honor
in the east sea between the korean
peninsula and japan there is dokdo just
two islands
and a handful of rocks that have
nevertheless become one of the most
characteristic patriotic symbols of
south korea but how on earth could two
pieces of rock in the middle of the sea
where there is practically nothing going
on
have become an entire modern symbol of
anti-japanese resistance well to
understand this whole thing i think we
have to take a little look
back at some history
the dokto islets are also known
internationally as liancourt rocks
or takashima in japan they are mentioned
in ancient writings that mentioned that
the islands belonged to korea as early
as 512.
during the time of the korean silla
kingdom in 1905 during the russia
japanese war the empire of japan
occupied them and shortly after in 1910
they were annexed like the rest of the
korean peninsula
as the japanese empire's own territory
that is why for koreans
dokdo symbolizes the first territory to
fall victim to the japanese occupation
of 1910 and to them it is part of the
territories colonised during that time
the fact is that once again after the
fall of the japanese empire in 1945
these islets were once again in korean
hands or at least that is what the
korean believed however for the japanese
they were no more than terra nullius
or no man's land and therefore they
could still claim them but didn't the
decolonization of korea and the
dissolution of the japanese empire
determine dokdo's future well
look at what article 2 a of the treaty
of san francisco said
japan recognizing the independence of
korea renounces
all right title and claim to korea
including the islands of kelpart
port hamilton and dagolet article 2a of
the treaty of san francisco as i'm sure
you've noticed the lien court rocks are
not expressly mentioned in the treaty
and that's the legal vacuum that japan
uses to continue to claim the islets
for this reason the arguments to defend
korean sovereignty of these islands
basically revolve around historical
geographical and even geological debates
yes geological ones koreans consider
that they are part of the continental
platform of the south korean island of
ulendo which is 94 kilometers away while
the closest japanese islands the okie
islands
are 157 kilometers from dokdo the fact
is as we saw with the senkaku islands
the diplomatic conflict over dokdo is
surprisingly more alive than ever in
part because of things like this
156 year old map may reignite
japan south korea island dispute dw
on that 1861 map dokdo was drawn as part
of the kingdom of korea the map had been
hidden until 2017 as part of the
collection of a japanese individual yes
i know ironically japanese who acquired
it in 1932. before that it was in a
library in pyongyang
[Music]
another document of japan's great
council of state dated 1877
said that dokdo had no relationship with
japan however friends there are korean
maps for all tastes where dokto is drawn
as korean territory and other japanese
maps that include it as a part of the
shimane prefecture all this
has led to a degree of myth-making about
who should control the islets and in
japan
at least in shimane prefecture they take
it quite seriously in fact
the pre-effectual governments declared
february 22nd as takashima day
and every year there are acts and events
claiming sovereignty over dokdo a
propaganda campaign that is not only
japanese but also south korean
although it may seem strange to us both
governments spend millions of dollars
every year to promote dr sovereignty
have institutional websites of their
respective foreign ministries trying to
explain the whole thing and even put ads
on the streets or in the subway yes
it may seem that in this part of the
world they're kind of touchy and what
can i say
you're right conflicts aside when it
comes down to it this
is really the desire to fight so who
controls these islets today well
right now it's south korea
[Music]
this country maintains a rotating
military contingent of 39 troops that is
permanently deployed on these islands
and even has residents who are elderly
and may have to leave the island very
soon to gain access to medical treatment
the most curious thing of all is that
the soldiers policing doctor
are usually young men from the
compulsory military service who chose
this place because they imagine that
they won't have to do much there
and they're right because there's
literally nothing to do literally
because on these islands there is only
one small pier
a guard post a lighthouse post box and a
couple of walking paths nothing else
[Music]
meanwhile japan has been proposing to
submit this dispute to the decision of
the international court of justice in
the hague
for years something that seoul rejects
because for them that would be like
conceding that there are doubts about
the sovereignty of a territory that in
their view was occupied by
force as part of the former japanese
colonization now at this point many of
you are probably asking yourselves but
what on earth does dokdo have that would
arouse so much interest from both
countries what justifies the deployment
of 39 soldiers or that the ministries of
both countries should
waste a single minute on this story well
friends this is where it becomes
interesting
[Music]
some reports speak of a huge gas deposit
in the region of uluwendo and dokdo
which could supply
all of south korea's gas needs for a
period of between 30 and 100 years and
don't forget that south korea is a
major consumer of natural gas by the way
as a side note did you know that dokdo
was once
bombed and no the antagonist was not
japan but the united states
in 1948 the us army carried out some
aerial missile practice exercises here
which ended very
very badly it turns out that just at the
time of the exercises there were about
80 south korean fishing boats collecting
seaweed the event ended with 16 koreans
dead
and the reputation of the us army at
rock bottom but friends we can't finish
this video without telling you about the
curious case of aquino terishima an
island that well
actually isn't even an island listen up
the submersible disputes
let's see what you think if i told you
that japan is devoting substantial
diplomatic efforts to reclaim some
islets
some rocks in the middle of the
philippine sea that barely stand
20 centimeters above sea level and that
have a total land area of barely 0.008
kilometers squared
what what do you make of that
we are talking about aquino terishima a
coral reef administered by japan that is
barely visible in the middle of the sea
with two rocks that have been built up
with concrete to prevent them from
becoming submerged with the high tide
this is virgin only absolutely absurd to
all appearances
it seems like a desperate attempt to
preserve some rocks that would most
likely have disappeared under the sea if
it wasn't for the concrete the question
is
why what makes someone pour piles of
concrete on some rocks in the middle of
the sea well there is actually an
explanation for all this
[Music]
what japan wants here is an exclusive
economic area recognition which
stretches about 200 nautical miles or
about 370 kilometers around these rocks
that's the same
granted to the coastal zones of any
continental country or that of populated
and consolidated islands
japan's intention in this case is to
overlap this area with china's exclusive
economic zone in order to steal a piece
of this
cake from them if the chinese were to
leave of course
of course for things like this where we
are talking about uninhabited islands
international legislation only
recognizes 12 multiple miles or 22
kilometers of exclusive economic zone in
these
exclusive economic zones the respective
states have the exclusive rights to
manage and extract the resources for
example
minerals or fish they consider
appropriate that is
to use the area as they wish in fact
exclusive economic zones have a lot to
do with all the disputes that we've seen
in this video normally countries try to
make their exclusive economic zone as
large as possible but in the case of
akinoturishima
it's i don't know how to describe it
dreaming beyond your means yet something
very similar is happening with iodo
[Music]
yodo also called socotra rock is a
submerged rock
4.6 meters below the surface that lies
between china and korea and is
administered de facto by south korea
with the intention of granting korea
exclusive economic zone rights over this
rock the government built an ocean
research platform in 2003 attached to
the submerged rock itself where the
south korean flag
marking its ownership is clearly visible
the subject of yodo might seem to be one
of the most surrealistic in this video
because the rock does not even appear
above the sea but it is just one more
example of how the three
great countries of east asia china south
korea and japan
tried to scratch out areas of influence
by any means possible and if there just
so happens to be mineral resources
gas or good fishing grounds as seems to
be the case here then
all the better
anyway friends these are the main
territorial disputes in the waters of
the sea surrounding japan
and although they may seem ridiculous
conflicts to many of us the fact is that
they stoke diplomatic fires that
sometimes see the tension pushed to the
extreme with military deployments
threats of sanctions and the risk that
for any step out of line
things could easily kick off and get out
of hand all in the name
of national pride why expanding their
exclusive economic zones in the process
anyway i hope that now when you hear
about these controversies you have a
better understanding of what they mean
so i really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine
also this channel is possible because a
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting
our mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always
i'll see you in the next video if you
want to learn more about politics and
world affairs and hear some more of my
lovely voice
come check out the reconsider podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider at
www.reconsidermedia.com or on apple or
google play or your favorite podcatcher